and her response is where is that name
is Jeremy
my name is shaquita my name is doing me
down hi I'm Troy I'm a gym employee and
this is my gym Horror Story in the gym
world there could be some scandals say
I'm at the front desk and this lady
walks in and as she walks in I'm
grabbing her can't scan tag saying hello
welcome to the gym and her response is
where is that I didn't know what to say
at that point and I was like I don't
know here talking about she starts
screaming at me like where is she I want
to know where she is I know she's here I
go get my manager tell him to come in
and handle the situation what we found
out was my co-worker was sleeping with
her husband how she found out was she
went to the doctor because she was
feeling sick she didn't know what was
going on and the doctors did an STD
check and found out that she had
chlamydia she goes to her husband and he
gives in tells her who it was tell her
it wasn't his fault she seduced him and
then she comes to the gym ready to kill
my co-worker
but instead I took and that was
horrifying so I just transferred from my
original gym to the gym out here in LA
and getting used to personalities is a
struggle here I'm just standing there at
the computer talking to my coworker and
the next thing you know my manager walks
up he's on the computer typing something
in few minutes go by and then there's a
lady behind the counter in a swimsuit
and she's yelling at him you're racist
you're disrespectful so then she goes
back to the swimming area or the locker
room the reason why my manager was
called back there was she was in the hot
tub and people were talking and there
were other people who knew each other
there and they were having a
conversation and she just flipped and
started telling him to shut up and stop
flirting with her and yelling at them
and someone came up to her and tried to
tell her like hey you're making people
uncomfortable and she got in his face
and got out the pool and was like
stepping on his foot pointing at him
getting in his face and then they came
to tell the manager and by the time he
gets back there she's just like swimming
in the lands like minding her own
business but he kneels down and like
to talk to her and she's like ignoring
him he keeps trying to get her attention
and finally she goes I don't talk to
black people here a strange man I don't
talk to you she just keeps swimming he
literally didn't say much she was like
okay well you're causing a disturbance
but if you don't want to talk to me then
I'll just get your account and we can go
put it in your notes for your account we
have this system where if we get any bad
members or issues from any members we'll
put notes in I am a little nosy so I go
back to her account and I see that like
all the way back to 2018 she has notes
this incident and many others are noted
on her account she's just nut she just
goes off on people and we've been
fighting to get this woman revoked from
our gym ever since and this was like two
or three months ago but every time she
comes in there she's rude to somebody we
just like keep making more and more
notes and we're still having a hard time
getting her revoked from the gym even
though she treats members badly she
treats employees badly it makes
everybody uncomfortable yet she's still
allowed to come and that was my gym
employee Horror Story the story that I
have is about a story about a guy
getting killed at the gym that I work at
I killed it in locker room by the police
officers the guy came in couple days
before he grabbed a girl but got his
membership revoked came back couple days
later with attitude so he knocked out a
security guard downstairs came inside
the gym so we called the police to get
him to escort him out of the gym you
want to follow orders he got into like a
wrestling match with the police officers
and they shot him unfortunately he's not
allowed no more that's the story but it
just was because the backlash that we
received after that incident transpired
the names that we could call and how we
get treated by different people who come
to the club looking for trouble
and that's the horrifying part is that
when you get blamed for something that
was not your fault when your friends get
blamed for something that wasn't a fault
we just follow orders in this situation
happen now we posted up on different
social media accounts
all of it because they come that we
worked for and like I say yeah and undo
whatever but everybody mad at us like we
pulled the trigger and that's the part
that's horrifying
and that's part of this circus it seemed
like don't nobody care about the other
side you know in a day what you did we
have doing those yeah and that's my gym
Horror Story man
so there was a member at one of our
locations who tried to get one of the
coaches she wasn't having it it was a
feeling them like that yeah he was you
know try to like you know go on like
little dates or whatever whether herself
and she was like no but he just kept
trying to progressively ask for more
like oh trying to like date her and
stuff and she was like not into it so he
got his feelings hurt so what he thought
was a good idea was he left a negative
yelp review about her and he said that
this coach sleeps with married men
all this stuff just like really like
putting all this business which wasn't
true and so she called me like in tears
like I can't believe this dude and then
he put on his name on the yelp review
that his name was Robert Barker so
luckily the owner he had some sort of
insurance with Yelp or whatever where it
was you could prove it was a fake review
they removed it but it took like a week
and it was just up there and it was on
the Facebook one too so this poor girl
had all this stuff like there all these
lies about her like a week I had to deal
with that all because of one man had his
family's hurt you know you get people
every now and again that would leave if
they don't get their way or whatever
they they'll leave like a negative
comment on Yelp because I don't know I
don't understand that whole mentality
but yeah that was definitely the worst
one that I saw I really wanted to fight
that to to what I saw that he
disappeared after that not because of me
and that's my horror story if somebody
says they don't want to date you just
move on you don't got to leave the
negative review
[Music]